[Music]
on this saturday night rebutting the
rules
increasing demands to drop the
persisting pandemic mandates at the end
of the day the current policy
probably isn't doing a whole lot as a
tory mp is walked off the hill over
vaccination status
plus the root of russian miscalculation
in ukraine i think he overestimated
himself
his generals that surround him and the
ability of his forces as we look back on
a hundred days of war
and marking a monarch milestone all
canadians want to see this
reconciliation evolve
and move forward the governor general on
what the queen's platinum jubilee means
to canadians
global national
reporting tonight
mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
calls are getting louder for the federal
government to drop remaining vaccine
mandates there aren't many left but they
do apply to those who want to travel by
plane or train and federal employees
including those working on parliament
hill abigail beeman has more on what's
left and an mp who says she was escorted
off the hill for refuting those rules
i was prepared to have them remove me
saskatchewan conservative mp kathy
wagontall won't disclose her vaccination
status but she says she's not allowed to
fly or take a train friday she took her
seat in the house of commons and says
she was warned she'd be removed she
eventually left on her own instead so i
just walked out and was walking down the
hill and the sergeant-at-arms who had
met me earlier in the day was halfway
down the hill and then he escorted me
the rest of the way to my car wagontall
opposes vaccine mandates and lately more
people agree at this point they mainly
affect those who travel by plane or
train and federal employees the public
service alliance of canada filed
grievances against that federal policy
in march i declare the motion defeated a
conservative motion to revert to
pre-pandemic travel rules failed monday
every single time we have been anchored
in science the policy seems to lag the
science and it has become incredibly
political doctors point to the science
of the omicron era as a reason to drop
mandates perhaps with health care
settings excluded data shows vaccines
are now less effective at stopping
transmission it's more like an airbag
than it is a collision prevention system
so it won't stop you from crashing into
the virus or encountering the virus but
it will stop you from going through the
windshield if you hit the virus you
neither say we're gonna lift it or
we're gonna require two doses plus
infection or two doses plus a booster
dose a third dose at the end of the day
the current policy probably isn't doing
a whole lot we asked the house of
commons about what happened to mp wagon
tall they didn't dispute her take nor
confirm any specifics meanwhile the
public health agency has extended
current travel rules until at least the
end of this month and the treasury board
minister's office tells global news they
hope to have an update on requirements
for public servants before the house
rises for the summer later in june
abigail b global news ottawa
the canadian military has raised
concerns about the ongoing harassment of
royal canadian air force aircraft flying
on a u.n mission to prevent smuggling to
north korea chinese fighter pilots have
been flying as close as 20 feet away
from canadian planes in international
airspace while giving canadian pilots
the middle finger prime minister justin
trudeau says it's extremely troubling
mercedes stephenson joins us now for the
latest and mercedes foreign minister
melanie jolie says canadian pilots have
every right to be in that airspace and
she says she'll take the issue further
nithu foreign affairs minister melanie
jolie says that she will raise the
chinese pilot's hot dogging directly
with beijing even though the chinese
government has ignored multiple
diplomatic rebukes so far
jolie also says she will raise the issue
at the united nations with the security
council
canada is doing the surveillance work in
the context of a u.n mission
and china being part of the u.n security
council we expect them to respect our
work
the behavior is raising concerns among
allies that the chinese government is
trying to expand airspace claims by
making it too dangerous for allied
aircraft to fly near china
this week on the west block i talked to
defense minister anita anand about just
how close those more than two dozen
aggressive intercepts have been
they put the safety of our rcaf
personnel at risk and in some instances
the rcaf aircraft felt sufficiently at
risk
that they had to quickly modify their
own flight path in order to increase
separation and avoid a potential
collision the defense minister is also
under pressure to act on the scathing
report on military sexual misconduct by
retired supreme court justice louise
arbor arbor says the military is sitting
on hundreds of recommendations from
various reports over the years and won't
change unless politicians do their job
and have the political will to force
modernization i'll ask minister anand if
she's willing to take personal
responsibility for that and how she will
address the concerns that this report
will just be more talk but not more
action
again i
totally understand the skepticism and
all i can say
is you will see the progress as this
year unfolds
we have
hit the ground running with this report
what exactly that means and looks like
are the big questions that remain for
the minister i'll be asking her those on
the show neither mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks and you can watch mercedes
full interviews with the defense and
foreign affairs ministers tomorrow on
the west block right here on global
as russia's invasion of ukraine eclipses
the 100-day mark reports say moscow is
throwing all its reserves at severo
donetsk a key city in ukraine's eastern
donbass region ukrainian officials say
they've managed to fight back and
recapture about 20 percent of the
strategic hub but the back and forth in
the country's east could be a sign of
things to come as both armies are now
locked in a fierce and bloody battle for
control of key eastern cities as eric
sorensen reports this isn't where russia
wanted to be when it first sparked its
invasion months ago
what vladimir putin called a special
military operation was in fact his
declaration of war on ukraine
russian forces struck from the air and
on the ground and from all directions
ukrainian cities were bombarded
civilians killed and tens of thousands
panic-stricken ukrainians began flooding
across all its borders i knew by gta i
mean the russian soldiers they kill
children she says they bomb schools
[Applause]
at first it looked like russia would
swallow ukraine and decapitate its
government putin and others thought the
capital keeve would fall within days it
was a gross miscalculation
the ukrainians fought back supported by
arms and intelligence from nato even
sinking a major russian warship
putin also underestimated president
vladimir zelinsky who many thought would
flee jim dobrevec a leader for institute
we are here said zielinski with other
government leaders becoming a symbol and
inspiration to ukrainians and zielinski
motivated nations around the world to
help global leaders came together and
much of the world united to stand up to
russia analyst marcus colga says
vladimir putin misjudged ukraine the
west and even russia's military
capabilities i think he overestimated
himself his generals that surround him
and the ability of his forces
putin has told russians all is going
according to plan but one more strategic
failure is plain to see
the brutal invasion of its neighbor has
caused other neighbors sweden and
finland to prepare to join nato russia's
goal of keeping the western alliance
away from its border is backfiring
spectacularly the last 100 days have
demonstrated that when the west stands
together we have a chance to fight back
against these sorts of authoritarians
but for all that has gone wrong for
russia there are no signs that putin is
losing his grip on power that he can and
will fight on
in the first 100 days ukraine has
withstood an onslaught and if the next
100 become a grinding war for territory
one question looms what would each side
accept to bring about peace
eric sorensen global news
toronto tonight in london two heirs to
the throne publicly thanked the queen
for her 70 years of service as the
weekend's platinum jubilee events
continued in the uk the woman at the
heart of the celebrations was not in
attendance but prince charles and prince
william joined thousands of onlookers to
take in a star-studded concert to
celebrate the queen crystal gomezing has
more now from london on the day's events
the image of her majesty drumming we
will rock you on a teacup sitting across
from paddington bear was surreal and
there were many moments just like that
a tribute fit for a queen
from queen
many wondered how guitarist brian may
could top his rooftop rendition of god
save the queen from the diamond jubilee
party but the band wowed as may rose
from the stage appearing to play on the
queen victoria memorial
the enormous crowd for the party at the
palace started gathering early saturday
the star-studded concert a huge draw but
the woman at the heart of the party was
the main attraction it's not only just
once in lifetime it's once in
probably the entirety of mankind
you know with monarchies on the decline
now and i really think that
it's not just
a british patriotic thing i think it's
the entire commonwealth
new images of the queen recorded in
april were just made public would you
like another one
the 96 year old missed the epsom darby
early saturday a favorite race of hers
she was also unable to attend friday's
service of thanksgiving after
experiencing discomfort the day before
with huge crowds all over and scores of
visitors
security is tight
trafalgar square which is opposite
buckingham palace on the mall was
evacuated the high commission of canada
located at the famous square locked down
metropolitan police conducted a
controlled explosion fearing a vehicle
left in the area posed a threat
the situation was handled in roughly an
hour the area reopened and the party
atmosphere restored
sunday is the final day and we will see
the gold state coach return to the
streets after two decades now the queen
will not be riding in the 260 year old
gilded carriage instead images from her
coronation will be projected onto the
windows of the coach
crystal gomezing in london thanks
crystal
coming up scenes of ruin and resilience
after 100 days of war in ukraine
when russia launched its invasion of
ukraine on february 24th some experts
predicted the capital kiev would fall
within days but not only is the city
still standing it is roaring back to
life our jeff semple is there and on
this 100th day of the conflict he
reflects on nearly two months of
reporting from ukraine and where things
could go from here
100 days ago few expected to be seeing
this summertime in kiev the ukrainian
capital is bursting with life it
honestly feels like any other major
european city during peace time people
drinking lattes during the day and craft
beer at night the city has roared back
to life from here it can be easy to
forget that this country is at war the
city hasn't been hit in over a month
[Music]
but of course appearances can be
deceiving if you drive out to the
suburbs you find communities lying in
ruins if you drive about 800 kilometers
east of here roughly the distance
between calgary and vancouver you arrive
at the donbass which is an active
conflict zone civilian targets they're
being shelled every single day a few
hours from there up north and harkeev
near the russian border ukraine's second
largest city is trying to get back to
life but remains under constant threat
told us the russians have not abandoned
their plans to capture this city we must
be prepared for them to try again he
says
we witnessed that russian retaliation
first hand while visiting an area
northeast of harkev that endured weeks
of russian occupation before ukraine's
military pushed back
as we were interviewing this resident
whose home was recently liberated
suddenly incoming mortar fire
after that it was time to leave except
for those who can't leave
the sick
the elderly and others with nowhere else
to go
so 100 days in that is the story of
ukraine it is a tale of two countries
really the peaceful west the war-torn
east and of course that is what russia
is trying to do to tear away parts of
this country for itself to claim some of
these russian-speaking communities but
after nearly two months in this country
we have not met a single
russian-speaking ukrainian who wants
that in fact many of them are taking up
arms for the first time
to fight back
jeff semple global news in keefe
and be sure to tune in tonight for 100
days in ukraine a global news special
hosted by jeff semple that's at 8 30
right here on global
ahead how the war in ukraine has created
new refugee trafficking risks
you're watching global national
when russia invaded ukraine 100 days ago
the world watched in horror as shelling
and gun battles erupted forcing women
and children to flee their homes into
neighboring countries leaving fathers
and husbands behind in search of safety
as karen lieberman reports so many have
nowhere to go they're desperate and say
they're being targeted and exploited
and her mother arrive in toronto
following a nearly three month long
journey from their home in ukraine
they're met by their canadian host kelly
abbott
on the morning of february 24th sagno
awoke to the sound of bombs falling on
her native keith
we was like in a dream we can't imagine
what happened and
fearing for her life she fled first to
poland then to germany and finally rural
ontario we met online and started
talking in private messages
and then we both kind of said oh yeah it
sounds like we could potentially help
you so many have opened their hearts and
homes to ukrainian refugees but with the
worldwide outpouring of generosity comes
a darker risk and much more dangerous
reality they see someone saying oh i'll
help you i'll take care of you like they
are in a very vulnerable position
sagno recalls being approached by two
men while walking alone in germany what
do you do where are you from i can
i can recommend you i can help you with
home you can come with me the executive
director of the un's gender agency
points to increasing reports of sexual
violence and human trafficking in
ukraine all raising red flags about a
potential protection crisis
the danger is also virtual on facebook
pages matching ukrainians with hosts
messages like this one shared with
global news asking when the recipient
will arrive in canada and if she's
looking to get married it is right for
human trafficking and modern slavery and
we do see
everything from sexual exploitation to
an increase in domestic servitude
sagno says she received a message from a
man offering a free apartment in toronto
you can come to my district to toronto
and i will
give uk
and you can stay alone on my flat and to
hear that you know someone was trying to
take advantage of people in that
situation makes me feel sad
julie jones who you heard from in our
report is also a former police detective
and intelligence specialist she said the
most vulnerable time is when people
first arrive no documentation very
little if any money and language can
also be a barrier so anyone offering
help may seem like a safe haven even if
it is not if you see something that
seems off make sure that you offer to
intervene or call your local authorities
nethu
karen lieberman in toronto thanks
next governor general mary simon on
meeting the queen and the monarchy's
role in reconciliation
[Music]
as the commonwealth pauses to celebrate
the longest reigning monarch 70 years on
the throne with a spread of events right
across the uk donna friesen who's in
london for the queen's platinum jubilee
sat down with canada's governor general
mary simon and has more on her recent
meeting with the queen
this platinum jubilee is such a
milestone for the queen for the monarchy
what are your reflections your feelings
about this moment in history it's a very
important
time in our history
it's really important for her
to see that she is very much appreciated
the crowds in
in london have been
tremendous there are you going to the
party at the palace are you
going to take that in rod stewart diana
ross yeah of course are you i'm here for
the party as well as the work
so i'm looking forward to it oh great
great and then sunday is the pageant i
guess right yeah i'll be at the pageant
yes
yeah i'm going to all the main events
and i have
bilaterals in between the different
events so
we're making the most of the trip you
have met the queen and what was that
like for you it was a it was a lovely uh
visit
she was very engaged and
and very warm and friendly
and made me feel very comfortable in her
home
the whole
visit to me
was a time for me to be able to express
to her
how proud i was to be to be her
representative in canada
she's she talked about her family quite
a bit and her children
and her grandchildren and that was very
good for me because i love my
grandchildren and my children so it was
a nice conversation to have
you were the first indigenous governor
general of canada
can you talk to me a bit about why that
matters when i was approached
to become the governor general
[Music]
i
thought about it a lot
just thinking whether it was something
that would be important for me to do for
canada
and i did came to the conclusions that
yes it was a good thing and an important
step in in terms of working on
reconciliation
canadians had been talking for many
years now on reconciliation but there
had been times where it was kind of very
stalled
and the revelation of the of the
unmarked graves
or the finding of the unmarked graves
really i think woke canada up
because it made canadians realize that
it was
they could actually see and
and feel
the impact of what it meant in terms of
canada's
history and i i do focus on
reconciliation a lot because
all canadians want to see this
reconciliation evolve
and move forward thank you so much for
taking time with us thank you very much
for having me
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
your canada is wiscana lake in regina
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna will be back
tomorrow from london have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
you